there are so many new Beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most typed products to test
for ourselves I'm a lip oil freak so I
was dying to try out these NYX fat oil
lip drips I bought so many they have the
huge doe foot applicator that I love and
a very subtle fruity scent this isn't a
perfect dupe for the Dior lip oil the
formula is slightly thinner and the
brush doesn't pick up and apply the
product as smoothly but these definitely
have more of a color payoff I do think
this is the best lip oil I've tried from
the drugstore for sure it feels so
comfortable and hydrating on the lips
and I love the range of colors they have
I haven't tried a powder foundation in a
minute this is the Maybelline Super Stay
hybrid powder foundation I just use the
little sponge that came with the powder
to apply it all over my already
moisturized and primed face this powder
is meant to give medium to full coverage
I feel like it's more full coverage but
it doesn't look cakey to me I didn't
even use concealer with this because I I
felt like the coverage it gave me was
enough I noticed that it did exaggerate
the dryness around my nose a bit but
some setting spray helped it all melt
into the skin and not look so dry my
other products Blended on top of this
just fine and it feels super weightless
on the skin and I noticed that I wasn't
as oily at the end of the day about face
release these cherry pick lip color
Butters and I am in love with these this
kind of lipstick formula is so popular
right now but this one is 100 my
favorite they apply like butter as the
name suggests just so creamy and
moisturizing it feels like a slippy lip
balm but you still get a really nice
color payoff and they kind of smell like
peaches to me but not in like a gross
super artificial way I highly recommend
these this is the Half Magic cheek fluff
I love that name because it describes
this formula perfectly it's this super
soft fluffy putty like blush that is so
buildable I genuinely think this blush
is foolproof like you can't apply too
much I'm typically very heavy-handed
with my makeup but this applied like a
soft flush of color it looks kind of
blurring on the cheeks which I really
liked it also comes in this compostable
and recyclable packaging which is so
great to see we have another transfer
proof lipstick to test out this is the
Revlon ColorStay suede ink lipstick this
really does feel like suede on the lips
it's a very soft and comfortable matte
finish that doesn't feel drying at all
for the most part they had really good
color payoff except this brighter red
orange this one was actually pretty
patchy so just a warning in case you
were interested in the brighter Shades I
did a little kiss test on my hand and
they actually are transfer proof this is
my first time ever trying Odin's eye
Cosmetics they release these Jewel shine
eyeshadows and I had to test them out
ignore that blue shade it came damaged
but I still wanted to Swatch It Anyway
there are two formulas with these the
multi-chromes and the shimmers the
multi-chromes are more expensive these
formulas are just so buttery smooth they
have beautiful glitter in them that
doesn't feel chunky and it doesn't give
you Fallout everywhere they look so
pretty and Shifty on the eyes and they
have like a billion colors it was so
hard to choose I really enjoyed using
these and I want to try more Odin's eye
products in the future this product
caught my eye one day when I was just
scrolling through Ulta this is the
Pacifica kind glaze dewy glow layer face
primer like that name reeled me in and I
just had to try it I was kind of
expecting it to be clear and oily but
it's more like a creamy slightly
pigmented gel it does add a really
Natural Glow to the skin like it's not
metallic looking I used my go-to
foundation on top and I think this is a
really nice primer my Foundation looked
really smooth and I could see that
subtle glow peeking through 16 bucks is
a lot for the drugstore but I really
liked this this is the statue Beauty lip
liner stain it's a peel off lip liner
that leaves the stain behind this is so
much like that peel off lipstick think I
tested a while back you have to leave
this on for 20 minutes which I thought
was a little nuts that's so much time
the first time I did it the stain was
just kind of noticeable I used the nude
shade but it looked way more pink than
nude I did it again to see if I could
make it more pigmented and it kind of
worked I could definitely see it more
but I feel like it just looked patchy I
do have a pigmented lip line so maybe
that's why it's not looking great on me
I feel like this is a good idea but not
a great execution house Labs just
released this color fused blush these
colors are just delicious I'm so in love
with them the house Labs powder formulas
are some of the best I've ever tried
this literally just melts into the skin
it looks so smooth on the cheeks and you
can build up the color really easily
like you can make these look as vibrant
as they look in the pan these are pricey
but I think a talc free formula this
good is worth it this is the Mac lash
dry shampoo mascara refresher and it's
supposed to soften your existing mascara
so your mascara is refreshed but not
clumpy I don't know if that made any
sense but let's talk about it so the
first time I tried it I applied it over
my mascara that was a few hours old and
it wasn't softening the mascara at all
then I realized this can't be used over
waterproof mascara so I tried it again
over my regular mascara and it worked so
much better this is one of those
products though that's like yeah it
works but at the same time do I really
need this probably not danesa myricks
released these yummy skin blurring balm
powder flushed blushes I think this is
the same formula as the bomb powder just
in blush form these are so pigmented but
in like the you need to be careful kind
of way apply too much and you will
regret it my preferred way to apply was
to warm some up on the back of my hand
and slowly build it up with a brush so I
have more control these are really
smooth and blurring they have this kind
of soft matte finish that looks really
pretty Alice actually influenced me to
buy the Sephora micro smooth face powder
years ago and I stopped using it for
some reason but I don't know why because
this is an amazing product it is the
smoothest silkiest powder that you can
do so much with it's described as a
powder foundation but you can also use
this to set makeup to bronze or to
highlight I just use this as an all-over
finishing powder and it immediately
gives you this soft focus finish it
applies so beautifully without making
your skin look cakey and dry I am
definitely obsessed with this once again
this
good apple full coverage transfer proof
serum Foundation I have to address this
immediately this is like four Shades too
light for me but we move I still wanted
to test the formula this has pretty full
coverage but not to the point where it
looks unnatural if that makes sense it
dried down very quickly and had a more
matte finish than I was expecting with
the word serum in the name it looks okay
over my more textured areas it didn't
look cakey and it felt lightweight on my
skin it's a very okay Foundation didn't
love it didn't hate it I just know that
42 dollars is a lot for it colourpop
released these adorable highlighters
that I had to purchase because hearts
these are more subtle than I was
expecting I did have to build them up a
bit but they didn't get Chunky or too
metallic looking they build up really
nicely I was mostly excited to try out
this lavender one because I never wear
color highlighter the purpley color was
pretty obvious but it actually looked so
cute this is the wet and wild 5 71
Essence primer liquid so you shake this
really well then apply it to the face
you have to let it sit for a minute
before you apply your makeup I actually
think this gave me a really nice base my
skin looked a bit smoother it looked
glowy and it had a slight tackiness to
it I tend to like a tacky primer all of
my makeup applied really well on top of
this and I didn't get oilier than normal
throughout the day this has a lot of
mixed reviews but I like this primer
these are the Charlotte Tilbury matte
Beauty blush ones people have been using
her highlighter wands as blush but this
is the first actual blush wand these
have amazing color payoff a little goes
a really long way but you want to move
fast with these they do dry down a bit
quickly but these are so pretty and they
blend out really well over other
products I love these another day
another glossy lipstick to try out this
is the Flower Beauty plump up gloss
stick the formula is thinner than I was
expecting just based on other similar
lip products I've tried it doesn't
really plump much you just get a slight
tingling feeling this feels so nice and
hydrating on the lips but it's more like
a lip balm than a lip gloss
foreign